so you remember I said to you before
most questions the vast majority they
give you a lead-in okay so here's the
lead-in I'm going to give you for this
particular result which looks really
terrible okay this is what I mean by a
lead you they'll say hey here's a result
that obviously have some binomials in it
so therefore you can take advantage of
binomial theorem if you kind of think
carefully about that result you can
twist and turn and manipulate it to such
a point then you'll get to this result
now before we go ahead and prove it I
did allude to this before this is this
sum of the squares of all of the terms
on a row of Pascal's triangle
apparently you add up all those squares
you get a particular number in Pascal's
triangle mainly this trick if you go to
Pascal strangle and say go I pick a road
ten okay and I square every single term
on there and add them all up have a look
at what that thing is telling you if you
add up all those numbers what should
they add up to on Pascal's triangle
where should I go actually good double
the number of rows down for a 20 and I
should look at the middle term okay hmm
that's weird
Pascal's triangle is weird okay it's
kind of like a reader black magic and
this is what we're gonna use to prove it
okay so here's where I'm going to start
remember the name of the game is by
comparing coefficients okay so I see
this in binomial so here is some
binomials over here one of the
coefficients on this side and one of the
coefficients on this side if I compare
them will give me this hmm so the
question is which side would you like me
to start with which one do you want to
have a look at first now my brain and
admittedly I have a distinct advantage
having done many of these questions
before my brain goes to the right-hand
side because it's one coefficient okay
so I can work out in this expansion
which one that should be and apparently
this is telling me a whole bunch of are
the ones on
side will be equivalent to that one
coefficient here so if I can nail down
which coefficient that is then I'll be
fine okay
now the second thing I notice is this
has a whole lot of X's in it yeah hold
on X's how many X's to see in this line
none so that tells you when you think
about comparing coefficients which
coefficient is the easiest to go for
which one has no X's in it it's the it's
the constant term the one that's
independent of X okay so at least now
we've got a rough trajectory through
this question let's have a go let's
consider the right hands now for the
right hand side in order to get to the
independent term the way I'm going to go
is by working out the general term first
that'll be the easiest way so I'm going
to say for the right hand side the UH
the case the term is going to be alright
help me up what is the kick term I'll
give you a clue it's not that now
usually we would say like
nck or Poinciana but in fact I'm on this
right like I'm gonna have two and all
the way up to the end that'll be the
highest power so that's gonna be 2 m C
okay yeah okay so how many X's am I
gonna have answer K of them which means
that the other guy this guy I must have
whatever adds up to 2n right that sounds
to me like two in minus K what do you
think yeah
okay let's massage this a little bit
just so it makes a bit clearer what I'm
dealing with the constant term the
turning dependent X will occur when all
of these guys exactly cancel each other
out
yeah so it will be a little more obvious
if I combine them into one term and then
I just make the power equal to what
again for independent of x 0 I don't
want any X's right so I want exit IRA 0
so I'm gonna go let's combine this this
is actually X to the negative 1/2 agree
with that so in fact if I get rid of
that I think
caimans two men what do you think - I
did that yep so now that I've got them
as in this on the same base I'm going to
combine them looks to me like it's so
now it's really easy to see where it was
not as obvious before okay the term
that's independent of X the constant
term I should say the right hand side
constant term is equal to well what
value of n will make this sorry what
value of K will make this or collapse
into zero and the answer is K equals M
because then it will be 2 n minus 2 n
that'll be 0 that's what I want okay
so therefore the constant term is term n
that's the one that's gonna make this
part collapse really which leaves me
with 2 n and oh that's a relief cuz look
that's what I have over here okay so
that's confirmation for me had I made a
mistake
maybe it wasn't actually supposed to be
the closing so I get something here that
doesn't match so much okay that was my
first shot how close am I to that what
do I need to adjust by okay so you're so
far so good
if I've got the constant term on the
right hand side what I need is to find
what's the cousin term on the left hand
side now B that they gave us this
identity you can see it's not gonna be a
walk in the park to find out what it is
but I want you to see if you can stunt
okay on the left hand side you've got
two binomials and you can work out just
like we did here what each one of the
terms is can you see if you can make
some headway going from here to try and
work out okay how do I sit down where
are the constant terms if you just mess
of like expansions and that kind of
thing they're in there somewhere you've
got a big clue is how to identify them
can you start with this line and see
what you can do have a shot